okay well I think of this talk as
alchemical youth on the edge of the
world because I thought what we would do
this morning is anticipate the
psychedelic 90s and talk a little bit
about the youth culture that is emerging
worldwide and some of the other
considerations that the youth culture
seems to be building bridges toward
altogether these various concerns seem
to me to add up to a kind of neo
shamanism or a kind of archaic revival
of social forms many of which have been
suppressed for several millennia
there are several facets to this new
emerging psychedelic youth culture of
the 90s first of all obviously the
ecology movement this is something that
was absent in the 60s when the awareness
of the approaching degradation and
destruction of the natural environment
had not advanced nearly as far as it has
today so there's a general awareness in
the youth culture that it's elders are
handing onto it looted polluted planet
in which very little planning or
provision was made for the saving of
resources for any future generation so
the ecology perception is part of this
emerging social phenomenon as is
feminism feminism has been with us now
for about 15 years but gone through
various forms and recensions
and seems now to have taken the form
that is very concerned
to recover the religious attitudes that
prevailed before patriarchy and history
established themselves in other words we
know that at some point in the past ten
or fifteen thousand years in the past
there was a partnership society which
imaged its supreme deity as Gaia a
goddess of the earth and a reawakening
of the awareness of Gaia and this really
goes to the ecology movement as well a
reawakening of this feminine ecological
earth standard awareness is definitely
feeding into the aesthetics of this new
counterculture that is arising now
another facet which is somewhat
paradoxical and perhaps on the surface
and seeming opposition to the concerns
of ecology and feminism is what I call
cyber culture or hacker culture this
means that a lot of people in the 16 to
30 year old bracket are very aware of
the underground uses and applications of
technology not only computers and
virtual reality and game making but also
desktop publishing Garage Band
rock and roll and a countercultural
record industry that often runs on very
small pressings of very obscure groups
and sounds nevertheless this
technological cyber culture is what is
making possible another facet of this
youth culture which is specialty
music a transformed rock and roll a
culture wide re you
vigor a ting of musical forms and of
course driving that concern is the
rediscovery of psychedelics psychedelics
which were very big in the 60s in the
form of LSD largely were almost lost
sight of in the 70s in the early 80s
when the management oriented yuppie
culture came along but now with ecology
with feminism with cyber culture in
place and cross fertilizing each other
psychedelics have become the natural
glue for this movement and they are
largely plants what is going on is an
attempt to recapture the shamanistic
institutions and styles that existed
before history and this means not only
cannabis which has been with us
throughout the 20th century throughout
all the counter cultural and alternative
moves of the 20th century but also
largely mushrooms mescaline and so forth
special emphasis probably being given to
mushrooms because mushrooms have gone
from being an obscure tropical deep
forest endemic to being something which
can be cultivated in any garage or
cellar in the land and many people are
doing this it's sort of an odd fact
about mushrooms that the qualities you
need to take them are precisely the
qualities that you will inculcate into
yourself if you learn how to grow them
punctuality cleanliness attention to
detail so forth and so on I really think
that the mushroom growers within the new
culture are the alchemists of the new
culture their formula is right amoled
and mold to gold
and thank God for them because they then
create the Jews that fuels the
creativity of these other concerns that
I've mentioned really the psychedelics
in my view should be seen as enzymes for
the imagination or catalysts for
language and really what the new youth
culture is attempting to do is to
reclaim the language forming machinery
for itself a culture can evolve no
faster than its language evolves what is
unspeakable is unthinkable and
consequently part of the task of the new
spirituality of the neo shamanism is to
empower language to go into areas where
it has never gone before particularly
the area of emotion it's incredible how
few words we have for our emotions when
we have so very many words for even
relatively obscure technical processes
so I see the psychedelics as functioning
in two areas first of all to catalyze
and empower the imagination and then
secondly to dissolve boundaries between
people I mean if you look at 25,000
psychedelic experiences the impression
that you will have is this experience is
one which dissolves people's boundaries
it doesn't matter whether they're
Hasidic Jew a communist party
apparatchik a rainforest shaman if they
expose themselves to these psychoactive
psychedelic plants they will call into
question their most basic beliefs and
assumptions this is what gives the
psychedelics their inevitable political
edge because the establishment and
maintenance
of boundaries is something that most
societies are very concerned with and
put a lot of energy into this is why in
the 60s the spread of LSD was viewed
with such alarm by the establishment
because it appeared that the machinery
of right-thinking Christian capitalist
society was simply being dissolved
before the startled eyes of its proved
heirs by virtue of the fact that so many
people were calling into question the
assumptions of the culture that they
were inheriting well now we see
something similar coming into being a
thirty years after the 60s we appear to
be poised on the edge of another youth
decade another decade in which youth
will set the social agenda for society
at large an attempt to lead us away from
some of the more lethal and
self-destructive patterns that we seem
to be so addicted to well now why is
this happening right at the moment while
I prefer to think rather than arguing
rationally about it that the reason the
20th century has been so repeatedly
disrupted or enlivened depending on your
point of view by these eruptions of the
avant-garde the Bohemians the beatniks
the hippies the youth culture of today
is because unconsciously we are actually
responding to the presence ahead of us
in the future of what I call the
transcendental object at the end of time
a kind of strange attractor a kind of
sociological black
Cole that reaches out to social
processes in the act of evolving and
puts a certain spin on them calls them
toward itself so that history in the
20th century is not a random walk or a
trend list fluctuation as we are taught
in the Academy rather history in the
20th century is a triumphal march toward
the revelation of a transcendental
object that lies beyond the turn of the
century every time we take a psychedelic
compound every time we slip into reverie
trance or dream we form a relationship
we encounter in mental hyperspace the
long shadow of this transcendental
object it's as though we've been moving
along a surface for a long time now many
centuries and now we are about to
undergo a phase transition or fall off
the cusp of the phase space and this
falling off the cusp of the phase space
is for those who experience it a
dizzying sense of freedom a dizzying
sense of penetration into a dimension
that was previously sensed and dreamed
of but which very briefly and
occasionally comes forward to be
realized it's a golden age similar to
the Golden Age of Greece or the
Renaissance but for us it has a
different character because this
transcendental object ahead of us in
time seems like a kind of concrescence
of all our hopes fears and intuitions
about what the future and the evolution
of our species could become
this is I believe why the UFO has been
such a persistent motif in 20th century
popular culture it's because we actually
sense on the unconscious level a kind of
approach of the end of time a kind of
closing distance between historical
societies and some kind of truly
mysterious truly transcendental object
that lies ahead of us in the future in
the near future and again returning to
the subject of the psychedelics their
role in all of this is that they seem to
pick up and amplify that signal coming
off this mysterious object hidden in the
future so that the contents of
psychedelic experiences when laid end to
end in a composite is to give a kind of
picture of what this final scenario of
global integration is going to be like
and though it is going to emerge as a
phenomenon of culture I think it will
largely come out of not our cultural or
cultural artifacts not our technology
but out of human organization itself
it's not for nothing that the self
transforming machine else that one
encounters on the other side of the DMT
barrier that what they seem to be
concerned with is the teaching
invocation and forced evolution of human
language I think that somehow the part
of human organization that is most
likely to undergo an evolutionary
transition is the portion related to the
production of language
even ordinary language which we take so
for granted when looked at from the
perspective of the rest of animal nature
is seen to be something very close to
the thumbprint of God on the human world
I mean you can take your dolphins and
your ants and compare them to a Grateful
Dead song or Milton's Paradise Lost and
it's clear that human communication is
going on in a domain of glorification
and completeness that is transcendently
other when compared to all other forms
of communication going on in the world
well then isn't it suggestive that when
we use these tryptamine hallucinogens
howís antigens which are strangely
enough analogous to neurotransmitters
within our own brains but then what we
burst through to is the equivalent of a
kind of shamanic finishing school where
self transforming machine ELLs
apparently the animal life of this
parallel continuum are urging us to
perform some kind of transformational
act on our own language well I had this
experience for many years before I found
anything in the world of human
experience ethnography or art history
that could be mapped on to it and then
in the early 70s I took myself to the
Amazon and I discovered there groups of
tribal people using a combinatory brew
called ayahuasca a visionary brew made
of a giant woody Liana called
banisteriopsis caapi and a small leaf
plant containing DMT called Socotra
viridis and when these two plants are
brought together and brewed together for
many hours and then boiled and
concentrated a very powerful psychedelic
substance results and the people in
these deep forest rainforest areas have
been using this shamanic preparation for
thousands and thousands of years when it
was first encountered in the early years
of this century the compound was
isolated and actually called telepathy
this was to refer to the apparent group
states of mind that the people using
this brew were getting into well later
it was realized that the compound had
previously been isolated from the Giants
Furion roux Pergamon harmala and that
the compound had already been named
Harmelin so telepathy
disappeared from the literature in favor
of Harmelin
but the thought is worth noting that
from the very beginning the early
explorers ethnographers anthropologists
who contacted this folk way in the
amazon assumed that it had something to
do with group states of mind well what I
discovered and I certainly wasn't the
first to discover it in the Amazon in
the early 70s was the people in these
tribal groups get together and they take
ayahuasca and their habit is to sing to
make music vocal music
they have no drums because in the Amazon
the humidity is so high that no drum
head could remain stretched more than a
few hours so the people use rattles and
leaf
shakers and vocal sound to produce what
we would think of as beautiful tribal
music but what's interesting about this
beautiful tribal music is after each
performance when you sit and listen to
the people criticize the performance
they don't say that it sounded very good
they will inevitably make comments like
I like the part with the silver bars and
the blue dots but I thought that the
yellow could have been more intense
especially where it faded into the
polkadot brown and gray section in other
words when you listen to these people in
these native contexts criticize these
performances you realize that for them
it's a visual performance it's sound
which under the influence of these
plants is actually beheld actually seen
by the people within this culture well
this was very exciting to me because you
see if you can see a situation from
another person's point of view in a
sense you have become that other person
to stand in the other guys shoes is to
see the world from that person's point
of view it's a very different way of
relating to language than the way we
ordinarily do it you see the ordinary
the ordinary way in which human beings
communicate is one person makes small
mouth noises the small mouth noises move
across through the air as acoustical
pressure waves they then enter the mind
brains system of another person and that
person consults a culturally validated
dictionary
to see if their definitions overlap with
the definitions of the person who
created the sounds in the first place
now if there's sufficient overlapping
then we say that communication is taking
place that understanding is occurring
but it's always a very provisional and
shaky kind of understanding and as
concepts become more complex
dictionaries become more incomplete and
more divergent and eventually two people
of the same culture if they're
discussing a highly technical question
may have no understanding of each other
at all
well this is very different from the
situation that arises if we could
literally see what the other person
means it's not without implication for
this argument that when we talk about
perfecting communication we
unconsciously reach for visual metaphors
so someone will say I see what you mean
or she painted a picture or his prose
was luminous
this means that we instinctively and
unconsciously believe that meaning is
something most clearly apprehended when
seen and one of the things that has
excited me so much about the aboriginal
use of psychedelic plants is they seem
to be on the brink of evolving forms of
communication which move out of the
realm of acoustical neurological
processing and into the realm of visual
acoustical processing well this has
tremendous implications for the new
world order that the youth culture
sure is seeking to put into place cyber
culture music psychedelics feminism
ecology the new spirituality all of
these concerns could profit and
strengthen themselves by appealing to a
visual language a new way of processing
what is heard this is what I think art
in the 20th century has unconsciously
been striving for ever since
jazz and cubism and throughout the
evolution of twelve-tone row Abstract
Expressionism rock and roll pop off
visual or virtual reality all of these
schools of art and technological
innovations in the art making process
are setting us up to be able to see what
we mean at some point in the future and
this will deliver us essentially into
the equivalent of a telepathic society
now you may have imagined telepathy as
something different you may have
imagined it as one person speaking and
another person hearing the thought
composed but this isn't it telepathy
will be nothing more than seeing what
the other person intends seeing meaning
now why it is that when we dose
ourselves with a human neurotransmitter
like DMT why we then encounter armies of
elves teaching us a perfected form of
communication this is a very difficult
question when you go to traditional
cultures shamanistic cultures in the
Amazon and put this question to them
they answer without hesitation when you
ask about these small entities they say
oh yes those are the ancestors those are
the ancestors spirits with which we work
all of our magic this is a worldwide and
traditionally the answer that you would
get from shamans if you were to ask them
how they do their magic it's through the
intercession of the helping Spirit who
is a creature in another dimension well
we may have imagined many different
scenarios of future technological and
social innovation but I think very few
of us have imagined the possibility that
the real program of shamanism would have
to be taken seriously and that shamans
are actually people who have learned to
penetrate into another dimension a
dimension where for want of a better
word we would have to save the souls of
the ancestors are somehow present it
isn't you see as though we penetrate
into the realm of the dead it's more as
though we discovered that this world is
the realm of the dead and that there is
a kind of higher dimensional world of
greater with greater degrees of freedom
with a greater sense of spontaneity and
a lesser dependency on the entropic
world of matter and that that other
universe is attempting to impinge into
our own perhaps to rescue us from our
historical dilemma we don't know perhaps
shamans have always had commerce with
these magical invisible worlds and it's
only the sad fate of Western human
beings to have lost touch and awareness
with this domain to the point where
it comes to us as a kind of a revelation
you see I believe that the whole fall
into history the whole rise of male
dominance and patriarchy really can be
traced to a broken connection with the
living world of the Gaian mind and
there's nothing airy-fairy about this
notion the living world of the guy in
mind is what shamans access through
psychoactive plants and without
psychoactive plants that access comes as
a nun confirmable rumor I believe that
the social style of human beings fifteen
to twenty thousand years ago was very
very different from the social styles of
today in the first place people were
nomadic pastoralists they didn't stay in
one fixed area but rather they followed
around behind their flocks and they in
the manure of these ungulate animals
that had evolved with the primates on
the grasslands of Africa was the
mushroom and the mushroom was acting as
a tremendous force for directing the
evolution of human beings away from that
of the rest of the anthropoid apes and
toward the unique adaptation that we see
as special to human beings today it was
doing this through a series of self
reinforcing tendencies that are easily
enough understood first of all when you
take small amounts of psilocybin such
small amounts that no psychological
experience is apparent at all there is a
measurable increase in visual acuity
what you don't have
to be a rocket scientist to realize that
if a hunting animal is in a situation of
high competition for resources and there
is an object a food item in the food
chain which imparts increased visual
acuity then those animals which admit
that item into their diet are going to
out breed the non mushroom using
population and gain a significant
advantage by this means well it doesn't
stop there if if slightly larger doses
of psilocybin are taken still sub
psychedelic doses you get what is called
C&S arousal central nervous system
arousal now all this means is a sense of
restlessness an inability to sit still a
sense of energy and the classical
meaning of arousal sexual arousal what
this means then is that those animals in
the population that were more successful
at hunting and obtaining food because
they were taking small amounts of
psilocybin are now going to act out what
primatologists call more successful
instances of copulation this means a lot
more sexual activity is going on and
wherever you have sexual activity it
stands to reason you're going to have
increased instances of impregnation and
successful birthing so the second factor
which builds on the first factor is the
mushroom using population will tend to
out breed the non mushroom population
and it will tend then to survive into
adulthood in greater numbers because of
the greater in
success in hunting the third and final
factor then which pushed these mushroom
using primates into a position of
ascendancy is psilocybin at the
psychedelic dose level actually
stimulates the areas of the brain that
are concerned with the production of
language so you get spontaneous
glossolalia spontaneous bursts of
modulated syntactically structured sound
and I believe probably that language was
invented long before meaning as a kind
of abstract exercise around the campfire
that these hominoids and proto hominoids
were doing for each other's amusement so
there you have a three step process
increased visual acuity means increase
success at getting food further doses of
psilocybin mean more sexual activity
with more instances of successful
impregnation and birthing of offspring
and finally contact with the language
catalyzing psychedelic tremendum that
even for people as sophisticated as
ourselves looms as the most tremendous
shocking and challenging mystery in our
world we have always been caught up in
the anticipation of the unspeakable the
human adventure has always been a
flirtation with these gigantic forces in
an unseen dimension this is what sets
our religions going this is what creates
gurus and messiahs and scientific
breakthroughs
it's that somehow we are in resin
with something much larger than
ourselves something which you could call
the Great Attractor the transcendental
object at the end of time the guy in
mind whatever it is we out of all of
nature seem to have a special
relationship to it and seem to be
somehow both under its care and somehow
involved in the manifesting of it in
three-dimensional space it's that as we
make our way across the historical
landscape toward the sensed presence of
this transcendental other so it is
making its way toward us through the
content of dreams psychedelic
experiences the careers of spiritually
advanced people the idea being that
history which is a state of extreme
instability and disequilibrium which
only lasts fifteen or twenty thousand
years that history is about to be
transformed or ended that the factors
that shaped history fanatic alphabets
male dominance materialism scientific
method empiricism these factors are
about to be made obsolete by discoveries
in the human and natural realm we we the
people of the high tech civilizations
are like the prodigal son we made a
descent into matter
we have wandered many years in the
wilderness now in a time of great
planetary crisis we must return to
the tribal fold we must take what we
learned from the peregrination into
history and return to the tribal model
with it only in that way then can we
reclaim our sexuality reclaim our
identities and reclaim the planet for
itself the styles that have evolved
within history the styles of male
dominance concern for tracing male lines
of paternity private property control of
female so forth and so on
all this has arisen as a result of the
establishing and maintaining of the ego
the ego is the function of the
personality that is most at home and at
ease within the context of history but
really this is not a situation of mental
health the ego is like a calcareous
tumor that arises within the dynamics of
the psyche and lodges like a cancer or a
tumor in the structures of the psyche
and the only cure or the only treatment
that I'm aware of
for the calcareous tumor of ego is
frequent repeated exposure to
psychedelic plants this is the essence
of their boundary dissolving function
and twelve to twenty thousand years ago
the ordinary style of human society was
as I said nomadic pastoralism
and psychedelic intoxication on a
schedule that was very probably lunar so
reclaiming
that orgiastic bound realists style of
sexual relating is part of what the
archaic revival is about obviously on a
with a population of six or seven
billion people we can't seriously
suggest that we return to the sexual
styles of a group of nomadic
pastoralists on the plains of Africa who
numbered probably no more than 50 or 60
people but we can understand that the
ego is a function that has arisen in a
sense to empower our most lethal
tendencies because as we look at the
earth as it exists today with rising
levels of toxicity and pollution and
arms proliferation and so forth and so
on there are no problems that cannot be
solved we have the technology we have
the money we have the industrial
capacity what we don't have is the plan
and the will to execute the plan
so really the change that we and the
groaning planet are waiting for is the
change in the human mind it's the human
mind that must change and then the tools
for the restructuring that must be done
will be found present and near at hand
and as far as I can tell the we we don't
have centuries or millennia in which to
do this change and if preaching alone
could have inspired it it would have
occurred several millennia ago what we
must look for is
a catalyst that is effective not on the
easy cases but on the hard cases and
when we carry out an analysis of that
sword what we're going to find is
psychedelic shamanism is the traditional
human response to our dilemma we must
dissolve the boundaries of yours and
mine of inside and outside even of life
and death we must dissolve these
linguistically conferred boundaries and
replace them with a sense of the
universal flow of energy through a
series of vibrating and resonant fields
of being this is the score philosophy
that lies behind shamanism Buddhism
Taoism this is the perception of the
perennial philosophy and I believe that
using the lessons of the 20th century
what was learned at Auschwitz and in the
haight-ashbury and the doluma Gordo and
Nagasaki using the lessons of the 20th
century the new youth culture can at
last create a viable human alternative
we're approaching the change of the
millennium we're about to go into the
third millennium and we can actually use
the change in the calendar as the wind
beneath our wings to lift us to a new
visioning of global completeness and of
species and planetary holism that will
then leave us the fitting inheritors of
the birthright of the elfin empowerment
I think we've said enough I think we can
knock off if they can't get seven
minutes out of that we have to
renegotiate